all doing the same [__] what the [__]
are you gonna do about it it's all the
same [__] you can't dwell yourself out
of [__] you can just love yourself and
forgive yourself and not judge yourself
out of it otherwise you're gonna be the
dark hole it's getting dark and [__]
darker and getting [__] darker
[__] fine light
[__] up okay end I mean it costs a lot
of money like and I say that with me
right like and what would we what are we
gonna dwell on about no I am that's the
thing I think you gotta really fight for
that for like why are you beating
yourself up like there's really no
reason there has there's really
genuinely no value in it there's nothing
good that can come of it are you
surrounding yourself with positivity or
are you kind of getting away and being
in a dark place definitely a dark place
right please watch this video over and
over